in death as in life Nelson Mandela is
revered for he forgave the men who
jailed him and saved South Africa from
Civil War I couldn't believe the
humbleness of of somebody that is his
statesman that can easily interact with
the Queen of England but also with the
poorest of the poor and on the 100th
anniversary of his birth there are a few
who remember what he was really like me
with my liver and holding his former
colleagues who loved and struggled with
the head of state and very seldom he
would listen to us all commander's
giving me advice that the president
maybe it's not a good idea to do this at
times you listen but most of the time
not Conor hello Conroy Henry Dean spent
11 years with Nelson Mandela serving as
his bodyguard reborn no matter ways in
the world you have these stack of
newspapers but don't you dare touch his
newspapers he will not read it if
somebody else paged through it he won't
have it in his early presidential years
still made his bed he would particularly
put his shoes in a specific way I think
it's the prism it's the it's the present
- if you can put it like that doo doo
boo too lazy was Mandela's assistant and
she says she never saw him angry no
because even if there was something
wrong and he will come in and then say
hello - how are you you know same fine
data then you say very good very - thank
you
in that's whatever
when the prisoner became president he
was given a multiracial protection team
and the driver told us that Mandela
worked hard to befriend team members who
were white was no love lost between
between us and the old God
however Nelson Mandela made sure that
these people felt very comfortable
sometimes we actually thought that he
was doing it at our expense because we
would think that really brought about
this democracy why must these people be
treated so well however they had to work
together when Mandela was accompanied by
Prince Charles on a visit to Brixton in
London and people jumped over these
fences and they keep the fences down and
then later on they were no offense and
the crowd was now in the road and
somehow the convoy that we had come with
became detached from the rest of the
convoy because of the amount of people
in the road Mandela and Prince Charles
left Brixton on their own so Flores
jumped on a motorcycle and found them
plus a startled officer at a local
police station former bodyguard
hurt Bernard witnessed Nelson Mandela's
best-known act of reconciliation when a
fellow security officer suggested the
president where the national rugby
Jersey at the World Cup final he put one
on one amazing day the president the
first ever black president of the
country wearing a springbok jersey what
is the world going to think about this
and what is the South African population
go especially the white South African
population I do you think about that mr.
Barnard on the Left says Mandela changed
the way he viewed his fellow human
beings
and that is a gift that lives on John
sparks Sky News in Johannesburg